then Higgins and Lauren Bushnell have a  belated engagement party the bachelor  couple has of course been engaged for  months but looks like they are just now  celebrating with family we are are now a  couple Lauren's sister Molly  instagrammed this cute pic saying the  family tore up the dance floor  finally celebrating Lauren and Ben's  engagement I think that's the part I'm  the most excited for the pair have been  spending a sexy summer together they've  gone on road trips hit up baseball games  and of course party for the fourth of  July and we're sure to see more of these  two they're getting their own reality  show is set to debut soon on freeform  beautiful person who I just can't wait  to share life with